porto mi piace questa debba state
facendo hanno capito si chiamavano alla
ricerca dello strike
[Musica]
e lo chiamavano giusto allora la mia
avete mai fatto un regalo con tutto il
cuore che poi si è rivelato una merda
e rimasta malissimo
vai vai vai suoli soliti poi voi
[Musica]
ieri
non so quanto possa riuscirci però ci
provo
non è vero non è vero non è possibile
[Musica]
retro no e retro gol ok qua non siamo
qua siamo sul tuo preferito però posso
istruirmi domani sono tutto tipo
veramente io perché abbiamo deciso di
passare il capodanno fa bello eh sì gli
ombrelli addirittura gli ombrelli ma sei
tutto scemo sento ricevo aprirvi dice ma
collega [ __ ] si dice come
trasformare l'acqua in ghiaccio in 3 2 1
al di là del sud è un'ala completamente
di jantscher e ha doti di flessibilità
serietà concretezza impegno apertura
mentale capacità di motivare gli altri
di sdrammatizzare i problemi
guardi cosa so fare inflessibilità
spedito anche se in questo caso se ci
sei batti un segno veramente di tratti
punta nei condomini e bellissimo
articolo antitutto sistemati jingle
bells jingle bells in goal show pisa 2
vaio maron
quant'è bello sto al bere
sei unico
[Musica]
quanto a questa la folla barca c'è pace
in quanto pkk che schifo oggi di vento
katniss everdeen
distretto 12
no non da salvare in vita adesso andiamo
a rubare lo zucchero filato as tecnico
sia caso
moretti per le [ __ ] viva viva la paz
era lì ma viva la basterà 0
4 la fine di uno youtube
io ne ho bisogno papà papà me lo compri
papa sony chi l'hai visto il canale
secondo te quanti iscritti
ma ovviamente non farò mai
devi stare calmo non farò mai ho detto
che devi stare calmo non farò mai
non farò mai
non farò se vuoi mangiare sushi e poi
porco diaz e cazzo letto [ __ ]
sbagliato sorry sorry cioè e cir anno fa
di peggio e l'ho visto sono i poveri che
sbrigano il vetro con l'acqua ai ricchi
la spina e con lo champagne non lo
champagne e big money alcun ai
cinquant'anni che ho ancora culo sporco
andando vai a anno ragazzo sta quello
anno ragazzo vai da maria maria aprì la
botta maria offriamo le cioccorane agli
amici quantifica che si apre sarà non
solo paoloni retto porco lui stacco di
questi mese mentre durata in maniche
corte come perché prendi la droga papa
la droga era pappa reale e papà di droga
papa
fatevi vedere fantasmi lo sto facendo
perché l'ho visto fare negli horror
quando c'è il protagonista di turno che
fa finta di fare il [ __ ] del tipo
fatevi vedere specchi e poi puntualmente
qualcuno glielo infila nel culo per
l'alba c'è l'ufficio di silente
direttamente porca [ __ ]
porca [ __ ] porca voldemort puzza è
bello dirlo potente
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bellissimo
era una penitenza era una penitenza è
piaciuta anche buona parte della notte
qui ma è una cascata qualificato
ma tra te e ho preso un regalo bomba per
natale sayan ha preso il regalo ti giuro
davvero siete proprio regalo frate non
dovrei prendermi niente è infatti niente
il regalo che fa per te ma vuote non c'è
niente niente per la persona che sa
tutto
se qualcuno a caso è ridotto orco
canta ancora staff magna come sei voti
verso questa qua sono tutti ma da
versare roba che ora e mezza
papà dei piedi
basta per non basta darsi da bere questo
mio fan che mi ha portato questa foto mi
ha detto che il tipo somigliava
esageratamente a me sembra veramente io
problema che non sono io mi hanno messo
tutti quanti il mi piace anche la mia ex
dc presentava lui alla porta che cazzo
cetoli mona vi è mi sento tradito dentro
citato la mierda 16v chiamano così video
ragazzi